[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imaginez un bonjour vous rendre au
travail comme d'habitude vous faire un
petit thé ou un petit café vous
installez confortablement à votre bureau
démarrer votre ordinateur et voir cette
image s'afficher à votre écran
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé à
l'entreprise du père de rami en 2016
tous les ordinateurs étaient affichés
avec ce message en crypté il demandait
une rançon en Bitcoin
et a mis d'enfance avec qui j'ai fondé
l'une des plus grosses communautés
d'investisseurs crypto francophone
à l'époque il a décidé alors de m'en
parler parce que c'est vrai en parler de
nos études on investissait déjà sur des
plateformes d'investissement pour aller
acheter des actions tout simplement en
bourse
et c'est là pour la première fois où
j'ai entendu parler justement de ce
fameux Bitcoin alors à l'époque on avait
essayé de faire quelques recherches
cependant il n'y avait rien du tout on
trouvait rien et encore plus rien du
tout sur les plus grands médias
mainstream c'est dans ce drôle de
contexte au final j'ai entendu parler
pour la première fois des crypto monnaie
on décide alors avec Rami de fouiller un
petit peu plus profondément dans des
blocs de geeks américains je me rends
très rapidement compte du potentiel
incroyable qu'offre cette nouvelle
technologie et pourtant elle reste
inconnue en France malgré le fait
qu'elle est vraiment très bien maîtrisée
et c'était une arme super bien maîtrisée
dans plusieurs autres régions du monde
et c'est vrai à l'époque je vous rassure
c'était que du charabia on n'y
comprenait rien je comprenais rien du
tout à la crypto monnaie rallie non plus
et que ça soit la blockchain la crypto
monnaie les Smart contract aujourd'hui
quand on demande à quelqu'un dans la rue
est-ce que tu sais ce que c'est la
plupart du temps on nous regarde avec
des grands yeux et c'est quelque chose
que je reproche énormément à cette
industrie aujourd'hui les professionnels
du milieu ont tendance à utiliser un
vocabulaire et un jargon difficile au
final comme signe de ralliement pour
exclure les autres de cette belle
nouveauté alors que je peux vous
expliquer ce soir qu'est-ce que la
crypto monnaie en seulement deux phrases
la crypto monnaie c'est une monnaie
numérique qui permet d'effectuer des
transactions en ligne elle fonctionne
grâce à la fameuse technologie de la
blockchain qui est un registre public et
sécurisé que l'on utilise pour
enregistrer ces transactions en ligne
si ce soir je suis là pour vous parler
des crypto monnaie c'est tout simplement
pour que vous compreniez que c'est
vraiment l'opportunité de demain et il
est crucial aujourd'hui je pense de
comprendre que les crypto monnaie est
accessible vraiment à tous peu importe
votre couleur de peau peu importe d'où
vous venez vous origines
vos croyances votre religion peu importe
ça n'a pas d'importance alors oui je
vous le confirme malgré tout ce qu'on
peut entendre sur les différents médias
tout ce qu'on peut entendre par ce qui
est dit par les différentes institutions
les autorités financières qui
aujourd'hui caractérise la crypto
monnaie comme étant rien ou alors comme
une hype libertarienne spéculative je
vous rassure il ne parle pas de notre
beau Bitcoin ou de notre hétérum qui
sont deux projets avec de très beaux
fondamentaux et des bases très solides
ils avaient oublié de le citer mais il
parlait plutôt des cheat coins alors les
cheat coins c'est quoi c'est tout
simplement des crypto qui ont été créés
dans l'unique but de générer des profits
rapidement elles n'ont aucune valeur
ajoutée à la blockchain et aucune valeur
significative par rapport aux autres
crypto-monnaies bon c'est vrai
auparavant moi-même j'ai déjà investi
dans des chiffres avec un investissement
initial de 1000 euros je me suis très
rapidement retrouvé avec plus de 10000
euros en quelques heures bon j'étais
comme un fou mais hélas c'était sûr au
moment de retirer c'était impossible en
fait c'était simplement escalier
alors c'est vrai ça peut être très
tentant d'investir dans les chiffres
mais je vous le déconseille très
fortement vous avez statistiquement plus
de chance aujourd'hui de gagner au
casino plutôt que d'investir dans ce
genre de projet et surtout si vous êtes
en quête de dopamine et au final vous
voyez c'est tout c'est
toutes ces arnaques qui ont créé une
mauvaise image autour de la crypto
monnaie mais aujourd'hui je vous rassure
on va parler de projet légitime on va
parler de projets qui sont de très bons
fondamentaux et je vais vous expliquer
comment avec de la maîtrise et de
l'intégration on peut très facilement
comprendre cette technologie de demain
alors pour mieux comprendre son
potentiel la crypto-monnaie il faut
revenir dans son origine parce qu'au
final pourquoi est-ce qu'on allait créer
une nouvelle monnaie en plus de ça
numérique alors qu'il existait déjà
l'euro ou le dollar pour cela il faut
revenir un petit peu plus tôt en 2008
lors de la création de la première
crypto monnaie c'était la crise des
subprimes le monde a été très fortement
il a été très fortement secoué par cette
crise internationale on s'est rendu
compte des défaillances de notre système
bancaire on s'est rendu compte également
de la corruption qu'il y avait à
l'intérieur c'est vrai à l'époque on
avait une confiance aveugle envers les
banques envoyer les banques comme étant
solide comme étant très forte et on
s'est rendu compte que les banques
étaient peut-être pas si infaillible que
ça et c'est dans ce contexte troublé
qu'au final Satoshi Nakamoto et venu et
à publier le livre blanc le premier
livre blanc sur justement cette première
crypto monnaie et il a expliqué comme
quoi c'était une alternative à notre
système financier il parlait alors d'une
technologie capable grâce au fait
qu'elle était décentralisée de venir
remplacer et annuler tous les
intermédiaires évidemment on parlait du
Bitcoin
alors aujourd'hui c'est vrai tout va
très vite en crypto monnaie on peut le
voir depuis que la blockchain et le
Bitcoin sont arrivés la première
transaction commerciale du Bitcoin a eu
lieu seulement quelques mois après son
invention c'était en 2010 un américain
était allé acheter pour
10000 Bitcoin à l'époque ça représente à
peu près 40 41 dollars il a acheté deux
pizzas aujourd'hui c'est 10000 Bitcoin
valent plusieurs centaines de millions
de dollars depuis les crypto monnaie ont
évolué très rapidement beaucoup de
projets ont été créés
très rapidement mais surtout les tous
les projets ont une valeur ajoutée
différente à la blockchain notamment on
peut citer par exemple l'Ethereum tout à
l'heure je vous parlais justement des
smart contract ce sont des contrats
intelligents qui ont été introduits en
2015 grâce à l'héroïne qui a permis à la
technologie de la blockchain défectuer
des transactions
automatisées alors oui aujourd'hui vous
allez me dire Thibault tu es peut-être
un rêveur ou un fou mais aujourd'hui il
y a plus de 50 personnes 50 millions de
personnes qui investissent au quotidien
en crypto monnaie mais surtout plus de
81 des 100 entreprises mondiales
utilisent la crypto monnaie que ça soit
comme moyenne de paiement comme moyen de
diversifier ses investissements ou alors
faire un transfert de valeur et encore
plus gros aujourd'hui le Salvador depuis
2021 utilise le Bitcoin comme monnaie
légale qui est venu ensuite s'en suivre
avec la Centrafrique
c'est vrai on dit souvent les crypto
monnaie ça va très vite mais on est
encore au début de la démocratisation
des crypto monnaie je vous rassure
aujourd'hui à peu près 300 millions de
personnes utilisent la crypto monnaie et
en possède soit un peu moins de 400
millions 400 millions ça représente 300
400 300 millions pardon ça représente à
peu près le moins de 4% de la population
mondiale alors bien sûr peut-être que ce
soir vous prenez pour un fou un rêveur
ou un visionnaire quand je vous donne
toutes ces stats et
je vous réponds justement ça c'est très
important aujourd'hui de comprendre que
le Bitcoin et les crypto-monnaies
suivent une courbe d'adoption en S comme
Internet des années 90 à aujourd'hui il
est vrai tout va très vite et pourtant
d'ici 2030 si le Bitcoin et les crypto
monnaie suivent cette même courbe
d'adoption et ça pourrait atteindre on
pourrait atteindre le milliard
d'utilisateurs sur les crypto-monnaies
alors oui c'est vrai on prend peut-être
pour un fou mais à l'époque Bitcoin le
bill Gates pardon me disait bien qu'on
utiliserait tous aujourd'hui internet au
quotidien il disait ça dans les années
90 et il avait totalement raison tout
comme l'intelligence artificielle a vu
le jour très rapidement il y a 10 ans de
cela on disait l'intelligence
artificielle non c'est pas possible ça
n'arrivera pas avant 50 ans et pourtant
aujourd'hui c'est déjà bien
d'ailleurs alors je vous ai pas si on
vous a prévenu juste avant que je rentre
mais mon speech a été entièrement rédigé
par chat GPT
en blessure je rigole vous inquiétez pas
et
bien sûr tous ces avantages dont on
parle depuis tout à l'heure il y a
également des menaces c'est normal
aujourd'hui j'assois le Bitcoin les
crypto-monnaies ou l'intelligence
artificielle il y a des personnes mal
intentionnées qui les utilisent ça
représente une infime partie des
transactions évidemment notamment il y a
des personnes qui utilisent le Bitcoin
grâce à son anonymat pour pouvoir à la
fois faire soit des demandes de rançon
soit blanchir de l'argent tout comme
l'intelligence artificielle et tu est
utilisée aussi pour faire ce genre
d'image des deep fake ou des fake news
ça c'est l'intelligence artificielle qui
a créé deux images complètement faussées
c'est vrai aujourd'hui on ne sait plus
ce qui est le vrai du faux sur Internet
mes bonnes nouvelles je vous rassure la
blockchain permet ne pas seulement de
divers les investissements comme on peut
le penser ou d'investir à droite à
gauche elle permet également de tracer
l'authenticité de tout ce qu'on va
trouver sur internet grâce à un code
unique qui est inscrit au milieu
justement de chaque transaction sur la
blockchain et grâce à ça on va pouvoir
tracer ce genre d'image et regarder
l'origine s'il s'agit d'une vraie ou
d'une fausse image alors là je vous
parle évidemment de tous les potentiels
avantages de la blockchain mais j'ai pu
tester les vrais bien fait de la
blockchain dans le monde immédiat et
réel pour pouvoir résoudre des problèmes
bien existants j'ai eu l'opportunité de
tisser des liens avec de nombreuses
personnes durant mes études supérieures
notamment un ami libanais qui avait
compris très rapidement le
potentiel d'investir en crypto monnaie
de diversifier l'argent de sa famille et
son argent en crypto monnaie et il a
bien raison quelques années plus tard le
Liban comme vous devez le savoir a connu
une hyper inflation les banques
tombaient les unes après les autres
comme un effet domino les retraits
étaient tout simplement impossibles et
lui pouvait disposer librement de son
argent car il n'y avait aucune
intermédiaire entre lui et son argent
grâce justement à la blockchain tout
comme j'ai pu participer à des
financements
pour des projets humanitaires en Afrique
qui me tenaient à coeur et grâce à la
crypto monnaie j'ai pu éviter tous les
intermédiaires pour pouvoir investir et
participer à ces projets ou également
selon le même modèle que l'Ukraine s'est
retrouvé avec toutes ces banques pareils
bloquées au début de du conflit avec la
Russie ce qui s'est passé c'est que
l'Ukraine a fait une demande sur Twitter
pour être aidé en crypto monnaie
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
dollars ont été donnés à l'Ukraine grâce
à la crypto monnaie donc c'est vrai
depuis 2018-2019 je ne vois plus du tout
la crypto monnaie comme au final simple
moyen de diversifier son argent ou
seulement d'investir je la vois vraiment
comme une nouvelle technologie qui va
révolutionner le monde à la fois
économiquement socialement
technologiquement sur beaucoup de
bienfaits je voudrais vraiment insister
et vous dire aujourd'hui que la crypto
monnaie c'est accessible à tous et
qu'avec un petit peu de motivation on
peut vraiment très très bien la
comprendre évidemment pour moi c'est un
éternel apprentissage et ça a été une
grande leçon d'humilité justement de
pouvoir apprendre tous les jours en
crypto monnaie maintenant depuis des
années donc je voudrais en profiter
aujourd'hui pour remercier les
cybercriminels qui ont pu trafiquer
l'ordinateur du père de Rami et qui
m'ont permis surtout d'acheter des
Bitcoin au plus bas mais si j'ai bien un
conseil pour vous n'attendez pas de vous
faire hacker par le pirate russe pour
commencer à vous intéresser à la crypto
monnaie merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]